[Music]
what up guys goes on here for anime
uproar until they have a very fun video
for you I'm super excited to talk about
the top 10 strongest characters an
attack on Titan I have already done a
who is the strongest Titan video which
you can check out but in this video
we're going to be expanding our scope
and you'll even get to see how humanity
strongest soldier Levi stacks up to all
of these insanely powerful Titans you
may be surprised if you want to see more
attack on Titan content give that like
button a colossal smash and if you
haven't already be sure to subscribe
because we have many attack on Titan
videos on this channel already and many
more on the way as is to be expected
with such a video there will be colossal
spoilers so proceed with extreme caution
now let me set up some ground rules for
this top 10 list since there's still a
lot that we don't know about the world
of attack on Titan it's characters we
will try to keep the speculation to a
minimum as you guys know if you're
caught up to the manga
Armin is now the colossal Titan and has
had for years because the time skip to
get used to new powers see I told you
there would be colossal spoilers in
addition we now know that the ninth and
final Titan power is the Warhammer Titan
so what does Armin the colossal Titan
have in common with the Warhammer Titan
you may ask well they're both not going
to be on this list we haven't seen Armas
colossal Titan or the Warhammer Titan in
action and this also holds true for rod
Reese's father who possessed the
founding Titan power as a result we
don't have enough information about
these guys to rank them appropriately so
they will not be included Eren and
Mikasa may also have gotten stronger
over the past four years but since we
don't know how much stronger we'll only
be using the information we do have
about them furthermore I will only
include characters who are conscious of
their actions so powerful mindless
Titans like rod Reese's unprecedented
120 meter class Titan will not be
included keep in mind that for the
purposes of this video we are not
looking at brute power but rather we are
looking at overall combat capabilities
with each character's unique abilities
being taken into account for instance we
know that before he died
Ben Folds colossal Titans had
most brute power compared to the other
Titan shifters
but as Reiner points out Zeke is known
to be morally strongest warrior we will
similarly be taking the individual as
well as the Titan power into account
lastly in this battle royale non Titan
shifters will have access to their
vertical maneuvering gear and the
associated weapons says even Levi's
humanity's strong a soldier would be
powerless against the Titans without
this basic equipment now without any
further ado let's begin this top 10 list
number 10 Mikasa Ackerman right from the
beginning we're starting off with an
extremely strong fighter in my favorite
character because a graduates at the top
of her class from the 104th Training
Corps this girl is insanely powerful and
has awakened like to other people on
this list ^ the Ackerman clan as we
learned recently the Ackerman's are
products of Titan science during this
awakening Ackerman's feel great strength
search through their bodies and know
exactly what to do as Kenny Ackerman's
father has pointed out even the royal
family who possess the founding Titan
power feared the Ackerman's because of
their power and their minority bloodline
which makes them immune to the power of
the founding Titan which allows the
possessor to erase or rewrite memories
of ldm that being said she does have
more trouble fighting typing shifters
and Levi does she cannot compete with
Annies Titan form into Titan forest and
even needs Levi's help to save Eren she
also needs the help of her fellow survey
Corp soldiers and a number of hungie
destructive thunder spears in order to
bring down riders armored Titan during
the return to chigan Sheena Ark it is
likely that her skills will improve with
age and experience and I'm excited to
see her in action after the four-year
time skip one day she may even rival
Levi's power but for now she remains at
number 10 number 9 bad thoughts version
of the colossal Titan as I already
mentioned in regards to brute power the
colossal pain takes the cake in the
official attack on Titan guidebook he
scored extremely well in every category
except in speed his power is off the
charts earning him an insanely
impressive 11 out of 10 Ryan even tells
Bedford that the colossal Titan is
supposed to be the strongest Titan but
the timid and indecisive vessels cannot
use the power to its full potential
this means that Armen may well become a
much stronger colossal Titan and feel
free to let me know what you guys think
about our man's colossal Titan in the
comments section below
anyways the colossal Titan 60 meter size
isn't all he has going for him he can
also create atomic bomb ask
transformations that have insane
destructive power the explosion
obliterates anything or anyone in the
vicinity creating a giant mushroom cloud
it is noteworthy that the armored Titan
is the only one who has shown to be
immune to his explosions which is why
these two Titan powers make such a good
team the colossal Titan also has a great
defensive technique although all Titans
release a certain amount of steam the
colossal Titan probably due to its
colossal size and height is the only
Titan that has shown himself capable of
using this theme as a deadly offensive
and defensive weapon when using this
ability even experience survey Corps
members cannot get close to the colossal
Titans mate because of the extremely hot
pressurized steam that severely burns
anyone who tries however the colossal
Titan power also has important drawbacks
we already mentioned that the colossal
Titan is very slow by far the slowest
among all the known Titan powers the
colossal Titan cannot move while using
the steam generation ability and it is
also burning the Titan skin tissue off
at a fast pace so you cannot keep it up
forever finally because of the massive
size of the colossal Titan vessel burns
energy a lot quicker he cannot stay in
his Titan form as long as other Titan
shifters and he has to wait longer
before he can transform again we saw
this when Aaron made contact with a
smiling Titan and used the coordinate
power to make the surrounding Titans
attack rider embezzles although Reiner
has been in his armor Titan form for a
while best halt is still not able to
transform even though his life is in
danger
he needs much more rest and recovery
time between transformations thus these
significant drawbacks and Ben Folds
inability to unlock the full potential
of the colossal Titans power mean that
this god of destruction
Blastoise settle for number 9 by the way
if you want to know more about the
colossal Titan in the other people on
this list be sure to check out our
attack on Titan playlist where we have a
bunch of videos focusing on
dual characters and their unique
abilities number eight writers version
of the armored Titan fun fact essay Amma
has said in an interview that the
armored Titan is his favorite Titan
design followed up by the female Titan
and then the beast Titan let me know
what your favorite design is in the
comment section below as the armored
Titan rider can surround his Titan form
with armor like skin he is powerful
enough to break through the gate of wall
Maria with a running start he is a
formidable fighter and the armor on his
fist significantly increases the
destructive power of his punches to the
point where one punch can blow off half
of the attack Titans head in contrast to
Bethel Reiner shows initiative and the
other training core members look at
Reiner as a leader he is more aggressive
than vegetables and challenges each to a
fight when Zeke says that they should
prioritize the capture of Aaron rather
than the rescue of Annie
although Bessel's is the one that is
actually in love with Annie he does not
transform to help Reiner
he simply watches the two fight in his
bed thoughts lack of confidence and
inability to take action on his own that
puts the reliable Reiner ahead of him on
this list
however Reiner has his weaknesses as
well there's no armor on his Titans
joint this makes movement possible but
it also means that Reiner has uncovered
weak spots like the back of his knees he
is also slower than most other Titans
because the weight of its armor he can
shed some armor to increase speed but
that also decreases his defence he is
also not as good at hand-to-hand combat
as Annie and Erin Erin uses the moves he
learned from Annie to defeat Reiner and
crack his titans armor during the clash
of the titans arc and for these reasons
Reiner will remain at number eight
number seven Annie's version of the
female Titan annie is a very skilled
fighter she learned how to fight from
her father who made her train all day
when she was a young child her fighting
style resembles muy Thai and her skills
carry over to her Titan form she has the
best and most lethal kicks in the show
Annie's endurance is also very
impressive after running alongside
horses for an extended period of time
and Titan form fighting experience
survey corps members outside and inside
of the Titan forest and almost getting
eaten alive by Titans Annie still has
enough energy to transfer
into a Titan for the second time kill
Levi's entire squad and defeat and
capture Eren her ability to summon
Titans to her proves extremely useful as
does her ability to harden parts of her
body she also has the ability to use
selective regeneration which allows her
to focus her regenerative powers on one
body part and drastically decrease the
time it takes for it to heal she uses
this ability to quickly regenerate one
eye and catch me by Squad off-guard
it takes Levi's and mica cells combined
efforts to finally rescue Eren and even
then
Levi considers the female Titan to be
too dangerous to go for the kill then
and there
Eren finally defeats the female Titan
with mycosis help who cuts her fingers
off while she is attempting to escape
over the wall in the official attack on
Titan guidebook it is made clear that
Aaron didn't win because of skill but
because he was constantly moving forward
and attacking while the female Titan was
focused on retrieve you can check out
our female Titan explained video for
more details about her motivations I
just want to note that there are
significant differences between the
manga and the anime where eren's Titan
enters what fans have dubbed berserk
mode but will address these changes when
we get to Aaron anyways after the survey
corps finally defeats Annie's Titan a
mysterious and impenetrable crystal
forms around her human body in the manga
and you still currently trapped
underground within that crystal now
although I do believe that at this point
Annie was still stronger fighter than
Aaron the fact is that as long as she is
trapped her skill level is frozen in
place in contrast or other characters
and especially Aaron have been improving
their combat skills ever since and for
this reason Annie will remain at number
seven number six Eren Yeager our
protagonist and the current possessor of
both the attack Titan and the founding
Titan although the founding Titan power
is dormant for the most part Aaron in
many ways has proven to be humanity's
greatest hope he used a giant boulder to
seal the hole in Shroff district's gate
this was the first time humanity took
territory back from the Titans he also
defeated the armored Titan and helped to
defeat both the female Titan and the
colossal Titan he used the hardening
power he gained after drinking Rod
Reese's bottle labeled armor to retake
Walmer
riah truly an incredible and meaningful
accomplishment as his titans name would
suggest Aaron is always attacking and
advancing humanity's cause eren's Titan
has immense strength which is
illustrated by the fact that he can lift
that giant boulder after he gains
hardening abilities he can harden his
fists enough to break the armored Titans
armor Aaron keeps getting stronger and
stronger
as he gains experience controlling his
Titan powers however the attack times
unique abilities are a bit of a mystery
among other things the armored Titan can
harden its whole body the colossal Titan
can explode the female Titan can attract
Titans the Beast Titan is a human
catapult with insane strength and
accuracy but what is unique about the
attack Titan well now we get back to the
berserk mode from the anime some people
believe that they just did that in the
anime to make the final site more
interesting which is possible but
perhaps there's more to it than that
Issei Yama has said in an interview that
he works with the anime staff and
sometimes gives them suggestions about
how he would have done some things
differently in the manga if he had had a
second chance
much like the Ackerman awakening is much
more pronounced in the anime perhaps
this berserk mode is a clue about the
attack Titans true power let me know
what you guys think what do you make of
the berserk mode and what do you think
is the attack Titans true power at the
very least we know that Aaron can become
infuriated at times and his power does
seem to increase dramatically in his
Titan form when this happened now let's
turn to the other Titan power that
dwells within Aaron he activated this
power when he made contact with Dean of
princes Titan because she had royal
blood in this instance he could command
surrounding Titans to attack any target
including Reiner and bental this is the
most powerful Titan power in the world
of attack on Titan and when one can
fully control it they can control Titans
erase and rewrite the memories of
Aldean's and inherit the memories of all
people who have possessed the fighting
Titan power with perfect clarity
however only those with royal blood can
make full use of the founding times
ability and Aaron does not have royal
blood I'm excited to see how far Aaron's
control over his Titan powers has come
after the four-year time skip and if
Aaron's come up with a way
to access the coordinate power some of
you even suggest a duct-taping historian
to him we will see like I've said in a
previous video I believe that Aaron has
the potential to become the strongest
living Titan shifter if he finds a way
to harness the power of the fatty Titan
but until then he remains at number six
number five Kenny Ackerman Levi's uncle
and the man that taught Levi had a fight
and survive in the underground
he's also been called Kenny the Ripper
and he looks a lot like Clint Eastwood
so you know you got to watch out for him
he looms over most other human
characters at 190 centimeters tall or
about six foot three inches tall despite
his seemingly slim build
he is the heaviest known human character
weighing 120 kilograms or about 265
pounds this must have something to do
with those crazy Ackerman jeans
Kenny too has awakened to his acraman
powers he felt a surge of power and knew
exactly what to do
Kenny keeps Levi humanity strong a
soldier on the run at trois
although Levi manages to barely escape
members of hanji squad are killed during
the attack
in addition Levi tells the survey Corps
that they should think of Kenny as if he
were Levi but on the enemy's side and
then he says no with those weapons he'll
be even harder to deal with
however unlike Levi who is in his 30s
believe it or not
Kenny is an older man and no longer in
his prime he seems to undergo a change
after URIs death his goal becomes
attaining the power of the founding
Titan so he can become even more
powerful however when he learns that
this is impossible because he is not a
member of the royal family he becomes
disillusioned and no longer has the will
to fight or even to go on living he
eventually dies from the severe burns
and blood loss caused by Rod Reese's
gigantic 120 meter class Titan
furthermore although he is an expert at
killing humans
he has virtually no experience of
fighting Titans so we cannot expect him
to be as effective in a Titan battle as
Levi is for these reasons the urban
legend Kenny the Ripper will remain at
number five number four Zeke's version
of the beast Titan Zeke is going to be
morally strongest warrior he definitely
has one of the most unique and
frightening
titin designs imagine Bigfoot but
extremely intelligent with insane
pitching skills in the official handbook
Zeke was given an off-the-charts score
of 11 out of 10 in intelligence which
means he is tied with a fellow genius
hanji for smartest character in the
attack on titan world his intelligence
makes him all the deadlier he's no
slouch when it comes to physical combat
either he crushes the armored Titan when
Reiner tries to disobey him and he does
so without breaking a sweat
furthermore Zeke likely due to his royal
blood has special powers that previous
beast Titan possessors has not had after
injecting his spinal fluid into LD ins Z
can give off a scream even while in his
human form that will turn the injected
LD ins into Titans that obey his
commands these Titans can even move by
moonlight unlike regular Titans also
Zeke is the only tiny shifter that
mindless Titans do not go after which
means that he would have a big advantage
over most characters in a Titan infested
area his ability to accurately throw
rocks at crazy speeds and over extremely
long distances makes Zeke one of the
best if not the best long distance
fighters in the series this ability
makes it extremely difficult for a bonus
to get close to him many have tried and
most of those people have died in the
process however the next character on
this list actually managed to pull it
off number 3
Levi Ackerman he was once a notorious
thug from the underground and now he is
considered to be humanity's strongest
soldier he is also the most popular
character attacks on Titan by far so if
you made it this far in the video and
want to show your support drop a hashtag
Titan Science in the comment section
like Myka Sian Kenny
Levi has awakened to his Titan related
powers he is a killing machine and he
can spin faster than Sonic the Hedgehog
without even getting dizzy he is the one
who manages to use the beast Titans
wallet items to his own advantage in the
return to chigan China Ark while the
Beast Titan is distracted by the
charging army Levi makes his way from
tight to tighten until he finally
reaches the Beast Titan he is so quick
that the beast Titan doesn't stand a
chance
Zeke even tries to harden his skin but
Levi is too fast
Zeke manages
to escape with the help of pique and her
Cartman Titan form but his fear of the
Ackerman clan is stronger than ever and
he prays that he never has to fight Levi
again Levi is so strong that he
literally has Zeke the beast Titan
himself Marlay strongest warrior quaking
in his boots this was a very exciting
battle
parlez strongest warrior versus humanity
strongest soldier and we may see them
fight again but if Zeke lets leave I
close the gap like he did before he
won't stand a chance in close combat
number two a tie between URI reefs and
145th King both characters were a royal
blood and possess the most powerful
Titan power the power of the founding
type they both lived full titan shifts
or lives about 13 years before they
passed on their Titan power to the next
member of the royal family this is
significant because shifters need time
and experience to master their Titan
powers in contrast Frieda Reese is not
given the time to master her titan
powers and this is why she did not make
it on this list even though she
possesses the same time powers URI and
145th King she is defeated by Grisha who
also did not make it on this top-10 list
she loses the grisha's attack Titan
because she is inexperienced she did not
have this long window of time to learn
and hone her powers but Yuri and 145th
King did which explains the big
difference between their power
we know that 145th king was extremely
strong even if he did abandon the
fighting on the continent and moved the
capital of aldia to the island of
parodies it is suggested that the
founding titan power cannot control
other Titan shifters since the 145th
King fails to keep the different noble
families who possess their own Titan
powers from fighting amongst each other
however the hundred forty fifth King is
able to control tens of millions of
colossal Titans and uses them to form
the three walls he also proves himself
capable of erasing and rewriting the
memories of every LDN within the walls
although he chooses to avoid conflict he
warns the marlins that if they tried to
infiltrate the walls he will send the
tens of millions of colossal Titans in
the walls to level the whole earth this
one King literally has the power to
destroy the entire earth
without getting off his throne which
means yes he is even stronger than Levi
as if the above-mentioned powers were
not enough already
the founding Titan possessor gains the
memories of previous possessors with
perfect clarity it's not like the other
Titan shifters who may see random
memories here and there from previous
possessors they can literally remember
everything all the way back to the first
founding titan possessor this means that
their combat skills will benefit from
the wisdom passed down to them from the
experiences and knowledge of all
previous possessors Yuri Reese as
mentioned lives a full ship there's life
and as a result it can be assumed that
he too learns to control and home the
founding Titans powers Kenny when he is
probably around his prime is no match
for Yuri even when there aren't any
Titans around for Yuri to control Kenny
the Levi's on the enemy's side so she
has never met someone more powerful than
him not to mention someone so
overwhelmingly more powerful the
knowledge that Yuri inherits and the
skills that he hones over the course of
his life as a Titan shifter mean that he
too could have controlled the colossal
Titans and erased the memories of the
lVN's but he never had the will to do so
the 145th King had more chances to
exercise the full extent of the founding
Titans powers law Yuri had extra
memories and experiences to draw upon
about a hundred years worth there is no
doubt that these are two of the
strongest characters to be introduced in
the series but even their powers pale in
comparison to the number one strongest
character on this list number one yamir
Fritz the woman that started it all the
progenitor supposedly according to the
marlins yamir made a deal with the devil
and became the first to gain the Titan
power this power was used to impress the
Merlin people in contrast the LDN
restorationist believe that yamir was a
goddess that helps her people in various
ways like through the building of great
structures including bridges across
mountains however whatever account you
look into there is no doubt that she was
powerful she had all nine Titan powers
within her it was only after she died
that her powers were split into nine
different powers imagine all the
different Titan abilities inside of
person and we thought that Levi was Opie
also there's the fact that there are no
other shifters
so no Titan would be immune from her
control we know that it is possible to
have multiple Titan powers within you
since Aaron has two Titan powers within
him the diving Titan and the attack
Titan so I'm interested in what would
happen if someone ate all of the other
shifters and had all nine Titan powers
within them would it be like the second
coming of yamir fritz
I don't know but I'm insanely curious
nevertheless if the legends are true no
one will ever be able to match the power
your mere possessed in life so it seems
like she will always remain the number
one strongest attack on Titan character
and so there you have it guys the top 10
strongest attack on tine characters in
my view I hope you enjoyed it I think
this will end up being one of our
longest videos so thank you so much for
watching and sticking to the end it
means a lot let me know what you guys
think who do you think will be the
strongest character after the four-year
time skip well the Warhammer Titan
shifter turned out to be the strongest
living [ __ ] there or will arm its
colossal Titan blow away the competition
I'm psyched to find out if you guys
enjoyed this colossal video make sure to
smash that like button and if you're new
don't forget to subscribe for more
attack on Titan videos like this one I
just want to also point out that we're
approaching 40,000 subscribers which is
just madness I'd like to thank each and
every one of you for your amazing
support until next time see ya space
cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]